M it's
God it's
God Muslim but you don't want to prove
he's Muslim I want to prove that Jesus
is a god you saying that you want to
prove that I want you prove that to me
so you don't want the 2200 no I don't
want I don't want a money I can give it
to a m j what I can give it to a m it
doesn't matter like I want my like I
came here right now to talk to you about
my point about being yeah you said that
right now after me Jesus a God you say
that right okay yeah you're right I did
that is one of the topics today all
right guys so he wants to challenge the
topic on Jesus being
God all right so what's your name for my
name is Ahmed ahed hey nice to meet you
my name's Avery all right so to prove
the do you that Jesus is God I'm going
to use something that's relatable to you
as a Muslim is that okay exactly okay so
I would ask you who is the first and the
last the first Adam is the first
Muhammad is the last no no no no no
that's not what the cuz like for example
Allah has 99 names right yeah all right
so Allah has these names that no other
creature no human or angel can share
these names with them you agree yeah I
agree like he can they can like put like
my English is not that good because I
didn't speak like clear English you're
doing good you're doing good yeah okay
but my English is not my first language
okay what's your question again um that
that Allah has names right these titles
that he can never like nobody can share
with him right
God is angry to go to hell angry can you
read this yeah and then put the name of
the God okay right so one of the names
that Allah has is that he's the first
and the last
means yes exactly so he's the first and
the last right that means he's infinite
he's Eternal right No Beginning No End
so nobody can claim this now if if
somebody was to say that they're
claiming to be the first and the last
that will be sh right y okay so this is
what Jesus says Jesus says in the Bible
he says in Revelation chap
22:13 he says I am the first and the
last the beginning and the end the Alpha
and the Omega I don't believe in the
Bible yeah but you told me to prove it
now you you have to prove it but not in
the Bible like in another thing because
I don't believe in the Bible I doesn't
believe in the Bible okay you know what
let me prove to you that you do believe
in the Bible okay like if listen if I
tell you something Quran you're going
you're not going to believe believe it
right because you you're saying that the
Bible is not true right the Quran is not
true right like you're not going to
believe in that okay so so how about
this how about this cuz I I like what
you're saying so can we at least say
that according to the Bible it does say
that Jesus is God right no like in the
Bible listen listen in the Bible he said
that give me one chapter he said wait
wait you're going away from it I gave
you one chapter Luke chapter verse I
gave you where Jesus himself says I'm
the first and the last that's name for
God and God alone remember okay like in
the Bible listen in Quran we we believe
that the Bible have changed like the
time CU that I don't believe in the
Bible that's fine that's fine you don't
believe in the Bible but all I'm asking
you is can we at least say If we're
honest that according to the Bible Jesus
Is God right no we can't say that okay
so in the Bible Jesus says that he's the
first and the last which is God right I
don't believe that because I say okay
like look for example like the Quran
says that Muhammad is is the last
Messenger right yeah right you you're
not like you don't believe in that I
don't believe that but would I be honest
if I said the Quran didn't say that no
you can't say that right I can't say the
Quran doesn't say that but I can say I
don't believe that I don't believe that
right so I can't say the Quran doesn't
say that so what I'm saying is is that
the Bible says Jesus says I'm the first
and the last so I know you don't believe
the Bible but according to the Bible
Jesus is claiming to be God right
yeah about that guys listen my point is
that I say that Bible has changed
because that maybe like someone wrote
that doesn't know that okay that's my
point so when when when would you say
that the Bible was changed before
Muhammad's time or after before
Muhammad's time okay before Muhammad's I
got you so let me ask you this thing too
would you believe that Allah is good and
just and loving right yeah I believe
that okay would Allah ever tell us to
follow corrupted chain scripture I
understand what you said I'm sorry like
would Allah ever tell us to follow to
believe in changed and corrupted
distorted scripture I'm
sorry change can you write it down okay
I got
you can you
uh can you write it for me can you write
um would Allah ever tell
you what do what you want to
say for would Allah ever tell us to
follow and believe
in
changed and
distorted scripture next to his M
only logic has his own mic so he doesn't
need
it take care brother God bless you man
like this is like this doesn't make
sense in Arabic with
all okay so let so you believe the
Bible's changed yeah I believe in that
would Allah tell us to believe in a
changed book no very good so if Allah
would not tell us to believe in a
changed book yeah but you believe the
Bible's changed yeah because no because
like how will already like like follow
religion has changed you say that he's J
but you doesn't believe in that I got
okay so when you go in the
Quran um there's a lot of a lot of
verses but I'll give you one chapter 2
Surah Bak verse 41 a 41 it says believe
in the Revelation that I sent down
talking about the Quran like what
chapter Bak chapter 2 you need to repent
Man chapter 2 okay verse 41
ver1 41 I 41
41 Surah Bak a
41 doesn't say that say that say what
what
it the love of the father he's not in
here is
atin that's the bottom that's the bottom
all right read read the yeah you're
right that's read read the verse before
that the verse before that
read
isind doesn't say thato doesn't say
believe in what we sent down believe in
what we sent down confirming what is
already with
you verse 40 yeah okay so so so the
reason why the verse was different is
because where are you from I'm from
Sudan Sudan huh I think you might be
using the war
kurran what I was giving me was the H
yeah the verse the verse numbering is
different the verse numbering is
different so but anyway it's okay so you
see how it says believe in what we sent
down confirming what is with you right
okay so I think the Quran is coming down
confirming what the Jews and the
Christians have there scriptures right
yeah now if they what is what they have
corrupted is it changed yeah it changed
so Allah is saying that he's sending the
Quran to confirm a changed book no it
doesn't say that the Quran saying that
uh uh how you say that uh wait
wait uh chain think like uh he's saying
that he will like there are a lot of
thing between like coming between Bible
and Quran a lot of things in common
similarities yeah because of like he
took the like the like cuz I believe it
changed like took the change thing and
he like make it uh like clearly and like
this but okay so if there's there's s
similarities and you think there's some
similarities and then there's some
things that are changed right but it
says that it confirms what's with them
so everything that's with them they have
because if it's changed then that Allah
is telling you to believe in a changed
book no wait show you
like calling
you do you know that that's that's you
don't believe that Allah would do that
right my point is this that if the if
the Bible was changed before Muhammad's
time then that would mean that Allah is
telling us to believe in a changed
distorted book but you don't believe
that Allah would do that he says the
Quran came confirming what the Jews have
and the Christian because all of them
before they called Muslims for the but
they had the Torah and the inil right
yeah because they had the zabor the
Bible so that means that the Bible
wasn't changed that they was reading no
like if you if like the Jews what book
they have the Torah Torah and Torah and
the Bible the same thing yes like if I
have a Torah and the Bible and like the
Tor the Torah is in the Bible the Torah
in the Bible you're saying that the Jew
and the and the Christian the same thing
yes the same thing why like they have
different name or different religions
because they they disbelieve they're
disbelievers just like they disbel that
Jesus is the Messiah right some of them
most of them they don't they don't
believe Jesus is the pro the prophet
from God right I believe in the Jes
Propet yeah the Jews I'm talking about
the Jews right so they disbelieve right
their hearts are hardened they're
stubborn people okay so but that doesn't
mean that what we have isn't the truth
love you brother doesn't mean that so we
have the truth they just disbelieve in
the scripture and the Quran says that it
says that they believe in some parts of
the scripture but they reject other
parts of the scripture right and the
Quran says whoever does that they are
disgraced in this life they're bad
they're that's the wrong thing to do so
I would tell you the same thing that you
can't choose some parts of the Bible you
say are good but other parts you say nah
that's that's bad you can't do that the
Quran says that's a no no right so you
can't say the Bible is changed if you do
then you're going against Allah okay I I
will give you one example let's say I
have a headphones okay and he has a
headphones and you have a headphone I
will you will read like like say like I
will tell you something okay you can
hear it right you can hear it right and
you're just going to read my mouth right
yeah let's say my my name is Ahmed okay
you say my name is what's your name
Avery you say my name is every and he
will say his name and that he say his
name and the other person he say like I
will ask him what's my name he doesn't
know my name right right okay he didn't
hear me okay right cuz here you uh do
you like memorize the whole Bible I I
don't memorize the whole Bible That's 66
books that's a lot it's a big Bible man
yeah because that like Quran like most
of the Muslims like M half the Bible or
more more than half it depend on the
Quran is like a little fraction of the
Bible like we have the the zabor is
bigger than the Quran yeah I know right
so like and the zabor is part of the
Bible so you have the zabor you got the
Torah then you got the inil all of that
is in the Bible all of them before the
Bible right there no so the B when you
say Bible you're thinking in Gil you're
thinking gospel huh the so look the
Bible is a collection it's a it's all
these books put into one okay so the
Torah zabor theil they're all in the
Bible
okay what's up same as yesterday oh okay
man
down the and stop I don't want to start
no worries no worries it's all good it's
all good it's all good it's all good
guys we're still going so
so so yeah so the bi so the the Bible is
a collection of all of those books okay
so when we're talking about the Torah
the zabor the inil which is all the
Bible the Quran says that it's true it's
not changed you can't believe that it's
changed or else you're going against
what Allah says that's my point you know
so because of that you need to believe
what the Bible says you have to believe
in Moses you got to believe in Jesus I
believe in them yeah but but have you
have you read their books I read their
books yeah you read the Torah yeah but
not all of it like just some parts just
some parts okay so okay good so if you
read some books and you have to believe
in the gospel in the gospel Jesus says I
am the first and the
last so that's why you should believe it
he said that in the one word in the one
part he said I'm a
God he says I'm the first and the
last can can you read that yeah I read
it yeah no problem all right
so you Muslim Muslim you speak English
okay good if if if if you want to talk
you can go okay okay just like show to
show the verse about okay got it so this
is what the verse says and this is
chapter 2: 75
it says do you expect them to be true to
you though a group of them me some of
them would hear the word of Allah then
knowingly corrupt it after understanding
it so it talks about how some of the
Jews used to hear the word of Allah but
then they will distort what they heard
they will lie about what they heard okay
which is true this what the this is what
actually what you brought up earlier did
you want your phone back is this your
phone okay thank you for that so they
will distort what they heard but what is
written it's the same they just lie
about what's written okay just like
somebody can have the Quran right and
they can see they can hear the Quran but
they can lie about what the Quran says
they can distort what it says right they
can't well yeah like like one second if
they say like uh you know Surah um
what's Surah
112 that one right right say Allah Allah
is the one right one but one right now
if now let's say I heard that right but
let's say I say see the Quran says that
Allah is two you can't say because all
the Muslims the same thing I know I know
I'm not saying that I'm saying I
distorted what I heard right that's what
I'm saying about the Bible and okay good
so you're saying people distort what
they hear but the scriptures is not
changed right change it can't be the
Bible like the Bible they change it
can't be how it can be because the Quran
says no one can change his words like my
friend let's see my friend I talk my I
told my friend his grandma had the Bible
okay my other friend his father has a
Bible okay okay we take our they P they
their Bible and then we put it together
okay like we open like chapter 27 like I
forgot the chapter not the same thing
there's something and there's something
that's the old Bible and that a new P
not the same thing how you say that when
you're saying that there's some things
in the Bible That's not the same thing
yeah like uh the chapter like it's not
the same thing what like how I show like
you tell me verse 20 like I can see it
so can you translate for me so are you
saying I want to
translate I think you might be asking
about what it's called no I didn't ask
I'm telling you like about what like can
you translate that like
he was saying that
uh his his grandmother like had like a
version of the of the Bible and then
another one like uh a friend of his
friends got another version and when
they compare them they they found the
difference okay so yeah that's what he
say okay so it looks like what you're
talking about English translations of
the Quran mean of the Bible sorry so the
different transl not translating like
both of them in English yeah that's what
I'm saying so there these are English
translations that would have slightly
different wording slightly slight
differences the same thing with the
Quran like in the Quran you have
different English versions okay you got
like what it's called like YF Ali ptha
sah International and sometimes their
wording is different but the like in the
in the Arabic all of them is the same
thing and so in the Greek in the Greek
they're the same in the Hebrew they're
the same we have we have the we we have
the Hebrew we have the Greek we have the
Aramaic okay so we can go back and see
what the Hebrew said we can go back and
see what the Greek said just like you
can go back and see what the Arabic says
of the Quran we have the same access
make sense makes sense so all in all all
in all exactly so well not Rosetta Zone
but but but what we have is is that the
Quran says that the scriptures of the
past are true and that we have them it
says it we have them chapter 2 ver 41
this one says no no it doesn't no it
does okay no so look look no I will not
in I just just like this idea that 15
years old good you're smart yeah because
like if I will give you like a she do
you know yeah
yeah Arabic I'm I'm a I'm a in Arabic
like a I'm English will convin you
because I'm 15 years like I I speak to
sh you know what I spoke to a shake on
my YouTube video I went to the m are you
here like when you're here like I will
bring a with me if you want you'll bring
a shake with you tomorrow I can bring a
not tomorrow like like cuz tomorrow is
my last day I'll be in Washington Square
Park tomorrow tomorrow I will see
tomorrow if I can okay I'll be in
Washington Square Park though I don't
know where that is I don't know either
I'm new I never been here before okay
but look so I just want you to think of
this okay according to the Quran the
scriptures are true they have to be and
Allah can no one can change his words
okay so even if people lie about what
his scripture say
the scripture themselves they are good
even if people lie on them we read it
and check it okay and so when we check
it we look in the gospel Jesus says in
the inel I am the first and the last the
beginning and the end no one comes has
salvation except through me so that's
what I I just want you to think about
that okay think about that talk uh my my
you if you want to look at us on YouTube
check me out it's God logic okay God
logic check it out apolog you can join
all right take it man hey let's give it
up for him
man good stuff man we're getting a lot
of good conversations man good
conversations from Young Muslims are
coming up but for some reason Chloe my
my secretary why won't the shakes where
the shakes at we just read we just read
it manic we just read the C's trying to
show the now let just read but where are
the imams where are the shakes sh we hey
guys we let it know
thousands of people saw the post that we
were going to be here they all saw it
they watch my live streams all the time
they knew I was going to be here where
they
at where they
at all them it don't matter where they
at I told them come on the eighth come
on the 9th I'll be here on the 10th yet
they're sending the kids why are they
sending the kids man now now it's
good day here hey it's D daycare man we
go we going to change the channel name
to D daycare good Lord man but look it's
it's all good cuz this is the right
place for the kids right send your kids
send them because they're going to hear
about Jesus they're going to hear about
the truth about Muhammad the stuff that
y'all don't tell them they going to
learn today they going to learn today
they going to learn today all right hey
guys repeat after me Jesus Is God Jesus
Is God Jesus Is God Jesus is God the
Bible is true Bible is true Jesus is not
a Muslim Jesus is not a Muslim change
our mind change our mind change our mind
change our mind change our mind change
our mind let's
go oh my God logic
oh